hey my mother food hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to tea
party simulator 2014
oh it's time to get dignified up in here
okay
aww er space and mouse it's supposed to
be a coop like surgeon simulator T sub
party semi T simulators you're
simulating being British so let's get to
it what are we supposed to do I actually
have no idea oh well I'm having a tea
party with you
berry Barrington it's good to see I was
so glad that you could get away from the
lower class all the plebeians people up
there oh my good oh my goodness when I
all down all the keys the pinky goes up
oh it's so dignified and delightful Oh
Barry you seem to have lost your hat
there let me assist you with that we're
all mad tea-party aborted you made you
get so angry that they were later come
down after a murderous rampage okay then
I wasn't very dignified let's try this
again shall we oh my god you apparently
didn't like that goddamn hat there so
I'm gonna try to be as dignified as
possible I didn't know that I was
supposed to please you my lord so I have
a box here what oh it's a tea box
Oh would you like some tea sir how about
I grab you a cup with that please your
highness I am so sorry to trouble you
with the the makings of the no I'm
staring sorry about that
let me just ah ah I got that now for you
would you like me to pour you the hot
water
they died oh god oh god I'm going to
just pour it into this cup here because
in all honesty I liked it better than
the other one anyway Barrington seems a
little bit of that oh dear he looks like
you're completely yes absolutely berry
I'm so sorry I have no idea what I'm
doing
shall I get you a plate willwill mine do
please don't kill me sir
I know what happened to the last
assistant not slave subject assistant
I'm sorry I just need to make you the
tea now before the water gets cold
remember to always be dignified it's
also disturbing how realistically hairy
my arm is oh I miss it I'm sorry I knew
that there was some perspective issue
sorry Barry I'll be with you in just one
moment
pedal it damn it I'm gonna get it
eventually Barry you just wait your turn
have patience sir and do not murder me
hey yo good good good get in there get
all mixed in nice and delicious now
Barry
I have your tea sir please take it I'm
sorry how about a biscuit in America
they're called cookies but here they're
called delicious biscuits I'm not a
buffoon
how dare no I'm sorry I should be more
polite you ignoramus
that's quite enough of that what is this
your stuff Barry what are you going to
do with me I have the knife ah quite
terrible this alright sorry I'll try to
kill you better next time it's not seem
- I say you're quite the novice aren't
you I'm trying to kill you I've never
killed a bear before oh let's just say
that's not how two parties are supposed
to go don't worry because if anyone asks
I'll tell them your real go 2d bodies
okay
thanks Barry spooky ah just like that
and I'll start you off with a biscuit so
that you can whet your appetite hey my
food sorry I guess that business little
bit give it you wasn't good enough for
you okay I didn't get it in there just
like that
but not too much like that oh what a
tastefully delightful amount
I'm not terrible at this in fact how
dare you
you've said that I've been terrible for
quite some time but in reality I think
you'll learn that I'm the best tea party
host in the world
I'm definitely not going crazy is that
of a [ __ ] and if there's a sniper out
there in the darkness just ready to take
me out as soon as I start summoning a
demonic entity through this bear oh
perfect
so how's your day Barry oh good day here
I heard that the missus this is about to
have a new baby is it yours
let me just scoop up some of this old
tea and there we go it's perfect
god damn it okay I'm going to get
something okay let me just leak water
into this cup what's the matter with you
you don't know a damn thing about me
Barry let me just point out and also
rock the [ __ ] on oh come now being so
undignified if I just kind of scooped
the tea bubbles this is boba tea we're
talking about now scoop it I say you're
quite the novice I say you're quite the
douchiest Oh God okay this is fine
everything is okay just don't god damn
it I'm gonna Wingardium Leviosa you to
hell and back okay so now I just need to
slice cake ha well didn't expect that
wow that is one sharp ass knife I'm not
a complete fool because here is your
cake slice and just like that the tea
party is over I did it I'm the most
dignified bread in America oh I got
enough hey it's good to see you
Barry Barrington I'm so glad you're okay
it's made of [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
leggo leggo okay thank you okay now it's
permanently attached thank you my nails
almost broke I'm so terribly sorry all
right you're all set okay we're fine
we're fine
everything is fine damn it Oh God
you son of a [ __ ] I'll kill you oh good
you know what screw you here's your team
won't stop until you're done with that's
why it's always like sauce build a door
we're fine Barry we're always there do
it I'm gonna do it guys i'ma do it I'm
gonna do it it's gonna be the perfect
Tea Party the perfect oh just like like
that
okay now more a little more different
like that okay now a little more
different like that and then set this
down gently okay I'll take the one on
the end then and there is your what the
deuce is this wait
wait for it this isn't exactly but this
is the dignified way I'm saying go screw
yourself
okay so maybe I'm not cut out to be
British but at least I was fancy enough
to get the tea party done so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more silly games that I
played in the past and as always I will
see you in the next video
duck is smart and apparently to the
Internet that duck is very sexy to some
people